so I tweeted a day or two ago and it's
it's taking off right the second talking
about it was three things and it was one
I don't support Trump I do believe in
free speech if you use your free speech
to take away someone else's then one day
they will come for you and I think that
really sums up what's going on here
because if you look at what happened at
the rally the other night it wasn't the
government that came in so it wasn't a
First Amendment issue the government
didn't say you're not to say this but if
we start getting to a place and I'm not
saying this is exactly what happened
that night because it's a little unclear
who started what and whatever but if we
get to a place where everyone is just
using their free speech to shout down
everybody else well then we don't have
free speech and it has nothing to do
with the government so there there's a
huge free speech play here too right
yeah well they call that the hecklers
veto
you're gonna let one guy scream
everybody else down so then whoever is
the biggest heckler is the person who
controls the debate and then yeah the
broader point you make is is perfect
because not to plug my documentary that
we're doing that we want to talk to you
about go away that's pissed off a lot of
my guys because it's called silenced our
war on free speech and they go no it's
not our war it's the thought war and we
want to think well there's a war on all
of us free thinkers and everything but
it isn't the government censoring us
we're [ __ ] doing it to each other I'm
afraid if I say the wrong thing to you
you're gonna think I'm a shitty person
you're afraid that if you post the wrong
thing on Twitter you're gonna get fired
from your job or people are coming after
you they're gonna call your advertisers
one wrong thing so we're all kind of
censoring each other we're really why
don't we just say well you know you said
that what do you really mean it
oh you're a trump supporter well why are
you Trump supporter well maybe maybe if
somebody would say well I'm a trump
supporter because I believe America has
the right to exist as a nation okay well
I don't know what do you mean did it did
it right you just talk that's what
people should do you listen to one
another and right now we don't we're all
declaring war on each other right so
that's interesting but it goes to the
people that are taking the higher road
here are almost destined to lose then
right because if you're taking the
higher road here and you're saying I'm
gonna respect your free speech you know
I'm good I don't likely say but I'm
gonna defend your right to say it if you
take that road well
basically from everything you've said
here there's gonna be a huge swell of
people that won't do that and thus will
always win with the hecklers veto right
that's where I see this all going that's
why I've been talking they were winning
but now there was a massive
counterculture where people are saying
you know me and Lauren the director of
the silence we said we're gonna make
free speech cool again you know we don't
have an agenda we just want people to
know that you know it's cool to share
your point of view it's cool to talk and
more people are getting that if you look
who's profiles are being raised on
Twitter which is kind of Twitter is
where the future is headed that's why I
love Twitter and we could do a whole
hour and just why I love Twitter yeah
what is the future the future is P even
though the business is crumbling you
mean the ideas behind yeah because the
people who are kind of I don't like the
word thought leaders but hip smart
tech-savvy people here's what they're
thinking they're they like people like
you they're like people like Laura
southern they're like people like Milo
they like people like Gavin Maga is my
profiles going so the people who are
sort of profuse free speech their
profiles are growing and then there's a
push back against a regressive left so
what had happened is we had given
everybody the hecklers veto to call you
a homophobe a racist the misogynist the
transphobic we said one wrong thing and
now you're realizing well that's
shutting everybody speech down now
before we have that the regressive left
the sjw's we had the moral majority
we had tipper gore trying to say you
can't listen I because you and I were
you know I don't want to say we're older
handsome men yeah the [ __ ] old man we
had ice-t body count cop killer oh my
god you know he's inciting violence uh I
used to bet I know anyone yeah
oh my god this kid committed suicide
after listening to Judas Priest this is
satanic music we're not a band that's
the right right and then you fought off
the right the left did and then the left
came in and now they're [ __ ] doing it
and now that instead of saying well
video games make you find they said what
video games make you hate women and then
we have a new counterculture that's
gonna push that back and then guess what
Sisyphus is rock you know guys like you
and me our whole [ __ ] life we're
gonna be like we'll be fight in ten
years we'll be fighting the right again
and then in another ten years we'll find
the left again yeah so that Center and
that bill you know it's interesting the
people that you just mentioned they're
like
and Lauren and Milo the earth again
they're all to the right and again this
I always feel like God I'm the last man
standing over here but yes it is it is
growing so how do we then coalesce
around that knowing that we're not gonna
support I don't I'm not sure who I'm
gonna vote for at this point but that we
can sit here and do this how do we
coalesce around that idea that we need
conversation more than we need everyone
judging everybody into oblivion
well I'm a little bit of idealist and I
truly believe if we're talking to each
other we're not killing each other
that's the start right
what a lot of people don't realize if
they haven't studied a lot of history we
you know we think we can't have a
Cambodian Holocaust we think that we
can't have an Arminian genocide we think
we can't have miles Great Leap Forward
or that what they had in the Soviet
Union why can't we why are we so special
well that all started with censorship
culture you can't say certain things
that started with us versus them from
the Cambodian the Cambodian genocide you
had the farmers were the real people and
the city people were the bad people that
was identity politics even within a
single race of people and then what
happens you don't talk you go to the
underground and then the [ __ ]
lunatics talk to only other lunatics
because they're still going to talk and
then you have all the lunatics on the
underground talking to each other that's
how you get people blowing [ __ ] up
that's how you get people killing each
other right so in an instance where you
know I saw two videos this week where
one a trump supporter was at a rally
screaming go back to Auschwitz and then
another one he was screaming at a black
person go back to Africa I think what
you're saying is that there's actually
something good there because it's being
unearthed as opposed to these people are
just festering they're screaming at you
and nobody's hitting each other
nobody is people are hitting each other
so well the protest is there's there's
no more than a music festival though the
line I always use is people you need to
get out more go to rock music festival
other than may probably Burning Man
nobody fights but other make you know
but if you go to a rock concert a rap
concert you we have people you're gonna
have people kind of fighting each other
and that's again media manipulation
logic verse is cognitive bias okay
logically speaking if you have multiple
rallies with 25,000 people there and you
have ten of them
and there's one fight that what is that
one in a hundred thousand that would be
the safest city in the world right but
you focus on that one fight and that
becomes a narrative
well there's violence well it was 178
year old guy punched a guy and you know
the face is sucker-punched okay well
there had been all these rallies and
there's a couple instances logically
speaking statistically speaking that
isn't really a big deal
well first off but just to push back on
that a little bit I mean Trump is also
offering to pay that guys legal fees
which seems pretty crazy to me a guy
punched a seven-year-old and punched a
black guy walking out regardless
regardless of his race but punch the guy
and Trump saying I'll pay for your legal
fees is a bet can you give me that one
he offered that was a different time
that you've conflated different stories
so that was a different riot where so I
guess there's a couple riots going there
are people there are people swinging
punches I mean did you see did you see
what happened when yeah I don't want to
give a guy free publicity but there was
a conservative Breitbart speaker who
gave a talk at Cal State Los Angeles
yeah I've videos of a Breitbart intern
being thrown to the ground by a black
lives matter protester I have the video
Lauren Feldman the director for silence
we have it mm-hmm
that didn't make news Yeah right that
sudden little violent I was both ways
and everybody do likes what the media
likes but I have no doubt the violence
goes both ways yeah every thing
everybody's doing it so that's the
interesting thing too about logic versus
not logic why don't we objectively count
well how much drama is going on at a
Sanders event right well he had a Bernie
Sanders supporter jump over a guardrail
to try to go to attack Trump right I
read the guy's tweets the guy is a total
nutjob yeah he's a nut he goes on CNN
and they treat him like he had stood up
to a bully right well why is he standing
up to a bully Trump why don't you say
well hey you don't like Trump Trump's
talking now you're trying to jump over
guardrail to attack a guy need posted on
Twitter before high one to kill Trump
and why isn't that yeah it's sort of a
nice way to wrap this thing up although
clearly we could have gone a lot longer
than this but it shows what a moral mess
everybody's in because I do agree with
that look I'm not thrilled with the
things Trump saying
I'm not supporting the guy but when that
guy rushed the stage if you look at the
history of this guy's tweets he's a bit
of a nut bag he said some crazy things
and then CNN treated him like a hero now
meanwhile if a trump supporter had
bum-rushed Bernie Sanders everyone not
only would say this guy should be in
jail but they wouldn't have given him an
interview on CNN but they'd also be
blaming Trump so yeah there is an
unevenness here that we gotta wrap up
but I think we did a little evening of
the playing field here what do you
think'll right we're creatures we want
stories want simple stories of the world
Trump understands it he's playing the
game better than everyone else that's
why they don't like him but yeah as long
as we're talking you're a human I'm a
human you know I don't want to kill gay
people you know cuz I know a gay guy
right I don't want to kill straight
white guys even though I D are the worst
you know ultimately that's what happens
with people as you as you talk to each
other you think well I mean you're
you're saying gay people are this or
this is that but I know a guy needs not
like that well that's not really large I
know a guy
therefore all gay people are this or
that is illogical but that's the way we
think so yeah as long as you're talking
you're reaching out to people who
disagree with you your own illogical
brain helps you become a better person
that's how you end an interview all
right so I want to thank Mike Stern a
[ __ ] and you can check out his book
guerrilla mindset how to control your
thoughts and emotions to live life on
your terms oh and direct all hate
directly to him it's at Serna vision on
the Twitter thanks again and we'll do it
again next week
[Music]